hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara Jessa and today I
went and saw Sola I'm in my best
Kirra cosplay that I could find from any
kind of source photos online so it's a
it's a bit off just need a gun and some
sadness inside me and I've got one of
them if you've seen any of my other Star
Wars videos you'll put together that I
was very excited for this film I have
been since they announced it I've been
excited about the yearly Star Wars movie
for the beginning of time since they
started it I I'm all about it
I love Star Wars content I have always
loved Star Wars Star Wars Star Wars
stood I know a lot of people weren't
very excited about this I know it's
getting a lot of like oh it's not great
it's okay but it's not great kind of
press a lot of people are a little
skeptical of like the solo stories not
just solo but like just like the one
person's story kind of origin thing and
I'll tell ya I didn't have any of those
concerns going in and none of those
really stuck out to me is actual
problems while watching the film I had a
really really good time seeing it I
didn't get bored I felt that it was
great backstory and and a lot of fun and
true to the characters and was it a 10
out of 10
rager like you know the last Jedi No but
I don't think that it was trying to be
that there aren't gonna be any hard
spoilers in here but I will be talking
about specific moments that happens that
aren't spoiler II so light spoilers I
guess this movie felt a lot like rogue
one felt where it was not a vehicle like
the force awakens and the last Jedi it
felt a lot more like a really wonderful
expanded universe it felt like the Star
Wars novels that I used to read like in
junior high school like going way back
to my Zima days it felt like that it
just felt like a really good space
indiana jones adventure film where
things are always happening you don't
get bored but nothing is like a shock
and surprise it's just everything
unfolds really nicely
really well paced and it serves its
purpose in a really lovely way I have
seen on a few spoiler-free reviews that
people aren't digging the young optimism
he has they're like well he's this a
kind of like crotchety dude who like
doesn't enjoy helping anything he kind
of wants to do things on his own terms
and he's also very grumpy about how
things are doing things when they're not
his own terms
I find that lovely because it's young
him and he's still it's like starry-eyed
and very excited about even just getting
his own ship and and you see the
backstory of that at which is lovely and
and you know finding his own you know
family his team and so I I like that
optimism that he has that doesn't bother
me at all he does a lot of work with
some voice play to kind of sound like
Han Solo Harrison Ford and a lot of the
times it hits I will say out of all the
characters
sadly my least favorite was Han Solo
it's kind of a bummer he in no way did a
bad job at all I just didn't find him as
engaging as the other characters and in
the grand scheme of things the other
characters are a lot less important than
Han Solo in the movie solo I I wrote
down in my notes I love here and she's
gonna die because I mean I guess this is
a light spoiler like I'm not saying that
that's what happens at all but I am
saying that in my mind when I was
walking into this film knowing that Han
and Leia have a thing in the end and
that everyone knows that they're so
beloved as a couple in a character duo
they're not gonna write the love story
of like the century for Kira and Han
they're just not gonna do that cuz they
don't want you know you feel conflicted
as a nadia ever so she's either gonna
die she's gonna betray him or she's
gonna fall in love with Lando
something's gonna happen and so I
thought initially that's what was gonna
happen I won't reveal what happens with
her but you kind of know going in that
that's a possibility one of these things
is going down it was a continuation and
extended universe kind of thing it
didn't feel like it was trying to it
wasn't adding anything new it wasn't
really shaking our boots hopefully the
people who didn't like last Jedi will
really like this because it definitely
doesn't change
anything in my mind I'm feeling like the
people who don't like this are also the
people who didn't like last Jedi just
cause in my mind that's funny to me you
in a sense get to know a lovely little
team for the film of course they were
gonna set up a small team aspect and
they were all really great I super
enjoyed the alien and the team a super
enjoy the robot I think in this and in
row one they did a really good job with
finding Comi through the robot and I
welcome that comedy I really like it
it's a it's a great contrast between the
seriousness of the characters the setup
of the name Han Solo really lovely the
set of getting the ship the Millennium
Falcon really lovely the setup of the
relationship between Chewie and Han just
stinking lovely the characters that
you've not seen before really great the
characters that you you know and love
and other films specifically Lando being
a very very very wonderful part of this
film just all really wonderful I don't
know that Donald Glover is bad at
anything he was certainly wonderful in
this I felt like he got the character of
Lando more than the Han actor got the
character of Han I know a lot of people
were like oh we just want a Lando movie
and I would I would I would second that
my favorite Lando line is I don't like
it I don't agree with it but I accept it
and man if that's not a mood I don't
know what is there were a lot of really
good one-liners in this film that I
super enjoyed and super had the tone of
han Solo and my favorite had to be I'm
telling you you will never have a deeper
sleep than curling up into a Wookiee
slap me I will say I didn't really super
enjoy the han and Kira love aspect of it
and I wonder if that's because like I
said earlier I just love Han and Leia
and and so maybe I was just like no I
was though a way bigger fan of Lando and
his robot friends I loved their
character and I saw
the Internet it was blowing up recently
very recently like last week that Lando
was pansexual I think is what it said
and I was like okay cool great cool like
stands to take and like the writer of
Lando hooligan invented Lando was like
yeah it's he's pansexual I was like very
cool but like if you're not gonna act on
it in the movie I really don't care like
white why bring it up at all if it's not
like you know it written into the script
that just kind of feels a little lazy
but I mean he's in love with his robot
so I I still was very much under the
impression that Kira was going to die in
this again I won't say if she did or not
but in my notes I really really thought
that she was about halfway through and I
did I wasn't loving the chemistry that
they had and so I was like if she's
gonna die which she obviously is cuz I
thought she was like if she's gonna die
they should have just made the love like
explosive like have just the chemistry
off the walls and just like have them
just like madly deeply passionately in
love because then maybe he learns from
that and then like brings that to delay
our relationship I don't know I just I
didn't feel like it was passionate
enough to warrant like being sad about
her possibly dying or her you know
whatever was going to happen with her I
I wasn't wasn't buying it in the notes
the end fight was relatively predictable
but in a way that was still really
entertaining and there wasn't really
anything in this film that was ever
gonna be like no like there wasn't any
like death any likes plot twists there
was anything that was just gonna like
blow you away in and in that case it was
just kind of like safely fun this was a
safe movie and it didn't need to not be
I don't upset me that it was safe in a
sense it's just like something that you
can throw on and watch and enjoy and you
know get a really nice backstory of a
character that you love and it worked
for what it was it totally worked
it really seems like they're setting it
up for something else another Han movie
maybe another solo movie we're against
solo not being han solo solo being like
a you know like a Boba Fett movie or
something and then like maybe that story
and falls into it kind of thing so it's
the
like there's more to be said obviously
there's so much more in the extended
universe to be said there's this
infinite content to be made in the Star
Wars universe which is so exciting I
know a little overwhelming to a lot of
people but overall I had a really good
time it just kind of felt like Han Solo
and the misadventures of him and his
friends and that's fun I wanted to see
that I really enjoyed it the characters
were really solid really fun and overall
the action was great the acting was you
know seven and a half out of ten I'd say
and it totally worked for me for the
chamber just saw of last Jedi and the
Tamra just saw of this I think I'm both
I'm both of them are just like very
different opinions from for most people
very unpopular opinions but that's
alright it's good it's great so fun it's
fun I have no idea what I'm seeing next
week but I can almost guarantee I won't
be in very casual cosplay so look out
for that thank you for watching may the
force be with you and I'll see you all
next week
ba oh and at the end han shot first
[Music]